hi everyone
i'm here to talk to you today about
procurement document ai
does your business have a lot of
receipts and invoices that you have to
do manual work for
do you hate having to type in every
expense for your expense reports
automate it with google's procurement
document ai
so what is procurement document ai and
what's the ai part of it
this is a solution that allows you to
turn unstructured content
into structured data procurement.ai has
a tooling for the procurement lifecycle
so whether you have handwritten receipts
you need digitized
utility statements invoices with coffee
stains purchase orders
credit and debit statements this stock
ai has got you covered
how is this smart why wouldn't i just
use ocr
well this solution has specialized
parsers for specific document types as
mentioned before
this service cleans your images and uses
google vision ocr to extract the text
then
understands the structure of the
document sections like
forms tables barcodes next
the word text and visual elements are
used for classification when required
google uses an ensemble of natural
language models to extract entities
so here it understands your line items
and all the information
related to it when entities are related
they are grouped together here
for example let's look at this line item
we're able to detect the related fields
such as
unit price and quantity they're all
grouped together in their response
what can you do with it once your data
is structured you can easily integrate
into your own app or database
or use one of ours such as bigquery or
firestore
then for everyone doing analytics out
there you can visualize it with tools
such as looker or data studio
i actually decided to use some code to
inspect my invoices in a google sheet
i started by uploading my files into
google cloud storage
then wrote a script to extract a few of
the entity types i cared about
and output them into my tracker
i can also inspect individual documents
with my processor
in the document ai platform
what was really helpful for me is that
it normalized the amounts and dates
so it's much easier to work with
programmatically
now that i have my data extracted i can
make charts to summarize my expenses
or automate them into a report so why
should i use it
you can increase operational efficiency
by reducing manual data entry
improve customer experience and informed
decision making
now you can bring the power of google ai
to your business's
procurement life cycle i hope we enticed
you to check out this new part of the
cloud document ai family
you can get started today with
procurement document ai
and the cloud console let us know what
you plan to build
happy processing
you